[Music]  two things are gonna happen first that  phone over there it's gonna ring second  you're gonna be wearing these cuffs just  gonna keep on ringing Oh that'll are you  I'm the guy you didn't count on Jack  Reacher Purple Heart Silver Star you're  a legend what else have you heard I need  your help someone's killing soldiers men  they used to be under your command it's  time to start hunting I don't know your  role this year I promise you I'll find  out nothing to find  maybe I rip your arm off beat you to  death with  it reaches to close is it going  I want being followed know you're in  third man one of us is that's a  certainty is that fear I hear in your  voice Jack what you hear is excitement  sorry he's not feeling hot might wonder  is this  you didn't count on jack reacher Purple  Heart Silver Star you're a legend  there's this dent in the dusk people say  you made it with someone's head I